so I don't know what it was that
possessed you to click on this video
today but you did and you're still here
for now at least so while you are I just
wanted to say thank you very much the
past couple of years have been very
transitional for me I've been doing a
lot of Aging as is customary for human
beings when I got out of the shower on
my 24th birthday recently I looked in
the mirror with my hair wet and slicked
back and I noticed that my forehead it's
got an ever so slightly larger than it
used to be like it's one thing to feel
like you're starting to grow up and
another thing entirely to have the
evidence written right there on your
face and I've been attempting to deal
with the fact that I am now growing up
by doing my best to embrace it by
drinking more grown-up drinks and
wearing slightly more grown-up shoes and
maybe most apparently four things on
your end doing my best to try and make
more grown-up stuff at the beginning of
last year I set myself the challenge of
trying to make five narrative short
films on this channel and by the end of
this week I will have finally completed
that goal pretty much anyway the last
two films are technically one long film
split up into two parts but it's five
films as far as I'm concerned anyway and
what started with a horror movie parody
starring T as the main villain is now
finishing up with a story about two
siblings grieving the loss of their
oldest brother like regardless of which
kind of film you might prefer it's
difficult to deny that my movies have
been getting more and more serious as
time has been going on what I don't want
you to think though is that this somehow
means that I don't still like making
silly funny things because I really
really do in fact that video in which I
dressed up as spider-man I had way more
fun making that than I did my last short
film but then again when I set out to
make a film about grief I wasn't exactly
doing it to try and have as much fun as
I possibly could I was making it because
I wanted to teach myself something about
how to deal with loss and I wanted to
share what I had learned through the
medium of a story I love video blogging
and I love filmmaking and both of those
things serve
very different purposes to me however
the process of learning that about
myself has not come without some
negative consequences making movies is
incredibly time consuming and I've had
to put the vast majority of my focus on
doing that and as a result I've been
neglecting video blogging and
in turn have been neglecting you and I
feel really really bad about that so the
good news for me is that you are still
here not everybody who watched me two
years ago still is but you are and if it
wasn't for your continued support over
the last however many years this has
been now like seven or eight Jesus
Christ
um I don't know that I would still want
to be here
you know you are the reason that I still
continue to be able to make what I want
to make and I am gonna be forever
indebted to you because of that so
that's why I wanted to say thank you
thank you with that I really hope you
enjoy my new short film our brother
parts 1 & 2 coming out later this week I
really hope it makes you cry because
that will make me feel really good
because I am secretly really really evil
and I guess I will just hope that you
will continue to support me as I try my
best to find a better balance between
the vlogging and the filmmaking and the
serious and silly and the the kid in the
grown-up but coexist within me that's
all good bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
[Music]
you just take a picture or something
no people need to get a full sense of
how you're doing so if you're filming me
then you better at least that good news